the latest figures from the office for
national statistics show 36,000 591
people in the UK have died with
suspected or confirmed kovat 19 up to
the first of May now crucially the
number of new deaths fell by over two
thousand to six thousand six hundred and
seventy-six and this is the smallest
increase for a month now deaths are
falling in every setting including now
care homes where nine thousand seven
hundred and thirty nine people had died
by the first of May but care home deaths
make up an increasing share of the total
in the latest published week they
accounted for forty point four percent
of Cova deaths in England and Wales
fifty-nine percent in Scotland and 60s
and 1.7 percent of those registered in
Northern Ireland and it's not just
covert deaths that are alarming there
have been many more overall deaths than
normal in care homes and in people's
homes the worry with increased domestic
deaths is they might mean some people
aren't accessing care for other
conditions like heart attacks or strokes
now looking at where the care home
deaths are happening figures from the
Care Quality Commission suggests the
Hartford share Hampshire and Surrey have
recorded for most deaths in care homes
they've also got the largest populations
heading further north and County Durham
Sheffield and Lancashire also make the
top ten in England now together these
figures tell a story of falling death
tolls across the country but also one of
a care sector that remains under huge
pressure